what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are about to do a first time watching
for a film that has been recommended our way quite
a few times and that is Tommy Boy and I am joined
by my great great friend fellow reject salamander
Sally Sally Lamonica all the way in the east
coast Sally how are you I'm great heck yeah that's
exciting to hear now listen we got a couple things
to mention first off please leave a like that
really helps out this video quite a bit secondly
um Sally I want you to use this opportunity to
plug what you got going on right now I mentioned
it on our community post I want you to talk about
it really quick why thank you Gregory Alba you're
welcome so I've been a fan of Spider-Man forever
even though I've been doing the Marvel movie
marathon I have never missed a Spider-Man movie
I decided to make a Spider-Man fan film from the
perspective of Mary Jane Watson courtesy of the
real rejects fans it wasn't my idea it was your
guys's idea like six years ago we are doing
an Indiegogo campaign to raise the rest of
the money I've shot four scenes already using
my own money we are just asking for a little
help if anyone would like to donate I'm sure the
link will be in the description for the campaign
and there is a teaser trailer based off the four
scenes that we've already shot so that's my little
Spiel it's looking great so if you guys want to
go contribute it would be uh I really appreciate
it even on my end I would appreciate it too and
Greg might be in it I don't know uh it might be
who knows we'll see what happens Spider-Man was
already taken so I don't know what role could be
left for me anyway uh we're gonna move on to Tommy
Boy right now very very much uh thematically in
tune with Spider-Man and as always uh full-length
to action watch long as we stick it with your own
copy for Tommy Boy Bilbo for super sexy Rejects
and over there we cover exclusively many shows
with reaction highlights and watch alongs included
Sally you ready to rock this boat I am so ready
because I love both of these actors I can't wait
to laugh my butt off buttocks off buttocks off
Mommy hurry up you're gonna
be late for school again
Lauren Michaels from SNL that makes sense
yeah actually he's probably on SNL this time
damn Tommy Boy grew up rich
you're pathetic shut up Richard
you're late too buddy thank you
hurry Tommy this is like
Spider-Man trying to catch them
whoa he grew up in like a second
runs pretty fast for a big guy honestly he's
killing it is he hitting his head against
ugh brings back memories Alfred Hancock
Herbie
oh my God I I passed
that's college for sure
I wish we'd known each other this is
a little awkward I'll probably go back
and work at my dad's loading dock like
always I love all you guys especially you
know that one dude looked really nervous
yeah he like panicked for a second so where's
my dad I thought he's gonna meet me at the
airport he was at the airport this morning
but you weren't on the plane yeah I guess
you should have called I did call earlier
where when was that or later when then it's
year I finally graduated yeah and just a shade
under a decade too all right oh that has to be you
oh my God you know I have never grown up on
Chris Farley really a lot of this feels very
different to me and maybe she's like two SNL
sketches of Chris he's very over the top but
that's like his thing you know hey would you
mind not eating in the car it's kind of a rule
hey what's new in the old gang from high
school I don't know Tommy I didn't really
like the old gang from high school
you're a stiff David Spade yeah
Mom you're talking about a huge
loan maybe instead of borrowing
it should take on a partner no no no there's
always has been always will be a family firm
my grandfather found him 21. my father
kept it running during the Depression
my son will run it hey Dad hey
look alive low bridge oh my God damn
he sells those really well yeah he does
what is this thing it's a buffer I take oil
filter that needs smoothing and help yourself oh
this is nice distance everyone is a
bad enabler here but he knows their
names this is awesome I I need fresh
capital for material for a new Workforce
before I can turn these machines on
look out oh no what have you done
why let's go yes sir
this is Dad loves him yeah good son that's
my name yeah that's your new office now
college grad hey there's even a fridge this
is great you can put six packs of soda in here
put candy bars in the freezer anything that
you want to keep cool you watch thank you
it's called reading top to bottom left to right
group words together as a sentence take Tylenol
for any headaches might offer any cramps
it's weird seeing David Spade play such a
straight edge yeah it's true it feels like a real
character yeah is that Rob White oh my God it is
holy schnikes
whoa are you sure it's not your stepmom are
you Tommy I'm Tommy this is an uncomfortable
situation I got an announcement to make Tom
I've I've asked Beverly to be my wife whoa
what'd she say
he's coming here today for the wedding Tommy
but my son is going to be your new brother I'm
gonna have a brother it's like Step Brothers
speak of the devil oh my God that scared me
brother I'm Paul you must be Tommy Brothers
don't shake hands we're brothers got a fun
at least not what I've seen
that's very you Greg if I sent a picture
of your mom to some of my buddies at school
she'd definitely be boner of the month
ah perfect which one you want huh huh
okay
is this your first time yeah Tommy it is you're
gonna remember this the rest of your life can't
believe you've never been cow tipping before oh
what you put your shoulder into her and you bush
and they fall over
those look like real cows they
are real cows that's scary yeah
me my turn over here these shoes are Italian
[__] off with cats this sword is going to
Columbus it's a one-day delivery but you've got
to mark down for two Georgia not Columbus Ohio
maybe you should go back to college for another
seven years and study a globe oh that's messed up
Michelle Brock chaperel high oh yeah I remember I
sat next to you in history I remember your brother
Dwayne we used to go to Safeway all the time
and get caught trying to steal Donuts he's a cop
I'd better not uh I have what doctors call
a little bit of a weight problem I used to
grab bear claws as a kid two at a time and I'd get
them launched right in this region here how about
some coffee I'd love some he's so endearing
I don't know how but he is oh yeah it's got a
real boyish quality about him yeah something
about that getting old and being alone yeah
it's cool you know I just want you to be
happy Richard seems so jealous of Tommy
yeah I Now Pronounce You man and wife you
may kiss the bride yeah lay one on her
so this is what it's like when
you get to a 10 year old wedding
party oh no inside joke people you
don't know what I'm talking about
laughs this movie couldn't be as
entertaining as that I promise
is that him really singing I don't know I
I'm still in shock this is happening that's
like great wow he's really just nailing it
ah what Dad somebody call 9-1-1 it is
like your wedding oh [__] sorry damn
that's tragic
it's a good transition when things get too good
in movies even though Tom is gone you'll remain
in our lives forever oh my God was he poisoned oh
I didn't think about that I was thinking Rob Lowe
did it to get the money or some [__] yeah
he looked like a psychopath that's what I say
oh Richard actually feels bad for him
that scent is getting to me that took such
a turn what the hell wow you're right in the
middle of a musical number I don't think I've
ever seen anything like that what happened
thank you foreign
he's just a lost boy I know one told
me we were watching Schindler's List
I'm gonna really miss him my father was a
great guy yeah oh my God why am I crying
that's sad it's just sad because he
died of a heart attack in real life
need a little wind here no you need
to drop a couple hundred pounds flip
Rascals I guess that's your
theory I just realized the
boat was like yeah she's really low on
his language in front of the lady Punk
and jam it over up your ass those
guys keep interrupting us I'm sorry
did I know where you live and I've seen where
you sleep I swear to everything only that your
mothers will cry when they see what I've done to
you Marry That Woman tummy yep just she's the one
that was awesome
this movie has more of a heart than I expected
I know Frankie if we sell well our values still
high everyone who owns stock in this company
stands to make a lot of money that of course
includes you Mrs Callahan now that you
and Tommy are the primary shareholders
if this Factory goes under the whole town
goes on and that's when those come in
and laying their trick money down twenty
dollars to pay the rent maybe instead I'll
spend it on the oh my God I'll give you
everything I've got my house the stock
then will you give us that loan you just
want to hand over your inheritance right
my dad said the new pads were the future
of Callahan but who's going to sell them
I will oh you got this time he's
running around doing a little behind
us once during the War I visited a prostitute
in my life has been a living hell ever since
I don't know much about this stuff but
he does that's right Richard knows more
about brake pads than anyone in here odd
balls bad idea I don't think anyone could
help Baby Huey out there on the
road you have a better suggestion
cutting right to the chase see I thought if he
was jealous of him he'd want to be promoted so
oh I can actually hear you're getting fatter
what are the three grades of Callahan
brake pads personal commercial and uh
Agricultural and what is our carrying
charge for all the merchandise in the
warehouse one and a half percent I
knew that why can't I remember it
this is the person uses ten percent of their
brain how much do you use one and a half percent
he's like four and 40 at the same time
are you ready yeah sorry I'm ready hey does
this suit made me look fat no no your face does
ouch all right now it's sale time so remember
we don't take no no [__] from anyone
take no for an answer oh yeah we don't take no
for an answer we'll take no [__] for video
no okie dokie oh got your thing
maybe I just like to add that the spectrometer
readout on the nickel cadmium alloy mix indicates
a good Rich strobe and fade decreasing
incidence of wear to the pressure plate
if you could just oh little fella you're not
speaking my language yeah you lack relatability
yeah our new brake pads are really cool
you're not even going to believe it let's
say you're driving along the road with
your family and you're driving along
then all of a sudden there's a truck tire in
the middle of the road and you hit the brakes
just now let's see what happens when you're
driving with the other guys you're driving along
the back seat I gotta go to the bathroom
Daddy not now damn it truck tired
I can't stop no what have you done Tommy
you were so close we screaming oh my God
oh my legs here comes a meat wagon
oh no you can see Davis may try to
keep a straight face the whole time new
guys in the corner puking his guts out
because you want to save a couple extra
pennies and to me it doesn't get out
do you validate no that escalated beautifully
yes hey chiefy could you tell me how far it
is to Davenport 22 miles okay I can't find
it on this map well get yourself a new map
just reverse the car a little bit
what is wrong with you
it's got to be on the map Davenport I mean because
you say it's 22 miles away and you're really smart
it's like cow tipping oh my God that's map
of Illinois which we're in on the border of
Iowa which is where Davenport is 22 miles away
you're in the wrong State get yourself a new map
he was right the whole time hey why don't you
pumping a gas they're all out they only got
diesel better go to the next station
how do you not notice his door okay
damn you guys are popsicle ow you want to
act like a baby I'll treat you like one
you're gonna act like a big boy what oh no they
were not daughters you won't have the company
no it's too bad he didn't leave me any cash you
talked to the banker yeah unfortunately your stock
isn't worth it until they sell the placement
that moment is rapidly approaching dang it so
they didn't kill him so they are mother and son I
don't know what's happening I'll see you Michelle
catch it yep you find them
out you won't sell squat
Tommy saved the factory that's the laugh oh my God
oh God sprinkle here
anyway did the brake pads work fascinating
observation Greg maybe he did lean over to
insult me you would have seen it coming what
are we gonna do can't just leave it here
what just happened hey won't you hurry
you know that thing in the back seat it's not an
air freshener it's a dead rotting deer carcass
I've been doing business with Callahan since I
hung out my shingle but I don't like you probably
never will I'm a happy little man and you treat
people like they were idiots yes before I decide
to keep my business with your place I'd have to
come by and have a look at your new operation
hey I tell you what you can take
a good look at a butcher's ass by
sticking your head up there but wouldn't
you rather take his word for it it's not
get it I quit I can't do this anymore man no
Tommy my whole life sucks I don't know what I'm
doing I don't know where I'm going my dad just
died time I drive down the road I want to jerk
the wheel and I'm a goddamn bridge in butman
we'll be in touch guys this is interesting I
can't believe he called me a psycho hey were
you in there just now you are a psycho good God
and comb your hair yeah well I wouldn't say you
did much better I thought you were yes the deer
ah
I think you're trying to bite me
oh no
wow I used a real deer oh yeah but that was
awesome yeah but sorry about your car man
that sucks yo Richard that's your
fault yeah he was like it's how
I fell I was like then who hit it it's the
guarantee that I make to the American worker
I want your truck to help you get the job done
it's like a Ghostbusters commercial we haven't
made one sale which means we only have to sell
about a half a million brake pads in the next 10
days or else the Factory's going under and the one
guy that should care about all this you doesn't
you doesn't is not a sentence and He does care
he's just stupid don't that guy in a little card
what is happening okay get off get I'm serious
explaining that I was seen all
of his properties being destroyed
the side eye
yes
oh my God laughs
that's like actually them
oh God
yikes
the brakes work
patience I'm not my dad that's right you're not
your dad he could sell a ketchup popsicle to a
woman in white glove I learned everything I know
from him I didn't have a father and he looked out
for me but you there it is hey I'm Big Tom's son
he'll fix everything so I'm allowed to be a [__]
fine give me your best shot I'll give you a
free one let me have Captain limpress try again
buddy is there a window open I feel a draft
do it or called your mother oh my God
songs are a character in the movie honestly
I thought I hit you on the shoulder
my shoulder doesn't hurt very
much but my face does right here
boy some chicken wings had really hit the
spot you sure it's closed yep it's closed
oh let me tell you why I suck as a Salesman
let's say I go into some guy's office let's
say he's even remotely interested in buying
something well then I get all excited I'm like
pet is my possible sale yeah I love it I
love my little naughty fat you're naughty
oh I killed it God you're sick I'll go turn the
Friars back on and throw some wings in oh my God
he made this person I did it hey you got the wings
because you were relaxed so you had confidence
your dad had that he was the best at knowing what
people wanted to hear and what people needed to
hear that's what selling is all about in a way
these people are buying you not just brake pads
yeah it's true they buy into you you gotta get
people to pity by yeah move them emotionally if
you're not talking about a guarantee skip it my
customers need to see that little label look at
them right in the eye hey you can get a good look
at your butcher you figure you put that little box
under your pillow at night the guarantee fairy
might come by and leave a quarter am I right Ted
how do you know the ferry isn't a crazy glue
sniffer building model airplanes says the little
fairy well we're not buying it he sneaks into
your house once that's all it takes next thing
you know there's money missing off the dresser
and your daughter's knocked up I've seen enough
oh my God because they know all they sold you
was a guaranteed piece of [__] that's all
it is isn't it hey if you want me to take a dump
in a box and Mark it guaranteed I will you might
want to think about buying a quality product
from me okay I'll buy from you I'll let what
would be good for us I hate this because
I don't know if they're actually related
I know but it just what does every Factory
need trucks they make stuff they've got to
ship it it's a must stuff the trucks stop
Tommy I prefer if they're mother and son
yeah I can't picture them as lovers
honestly she's like tried really hard yes
see Psychopaths
not good
yeah he was gonna shoot that
dog I knew he was Psycho
is homeboy about to pleasure himself it's not
it's not what the
what were you doing going over some documents
awkward you knew it hey that's a pretty girl
down there good for her geez I wonder if she
goes out with one of the Yankees what a random
bit since I come so comfortable who's your
favorite little rascal alfalfa or is it Spanky
thinner sinner
I'll buy yes I like what I hear Yes sounds good
by the way could you ever eat paint chips as a kid
oh God
I'm okay so you can see the mark on the window
that's impressive yeah he hurt himself for our
benefit for art tell me that's fabulous your dad
never sold a thousand in Oshkosh uh not since I've
been here it's not about where you come from
Greg it's about what you do with it she maybe
oh what is that uh ew that sucks
they're screwed
can you run and pee at the same time yes
it's very it's physically possible Sally
okay and it was a turn I think you
can too that'd be cool not that I'd
ever be in that situation so let's make a new
video let's see what we can do Tick Tock hack
this guy's going to be a human
deformity by the end of the move
it's giving Like Home Alone how messed
up can he look by the end of it I just
wanted to tell you that Tommy's been
talking a lot about you recently and well
so sweet you have no idea how much it
means having you in your mom's family
well between that and the sweetness
I'd say hang on to it oh la la
towels need sleepy I'll skip it keeping you
in my pillow please go away let me sleep
hey guess what I just called Autotech and
they decided to make an order that puts
us over the mark yes oh Richard I'm so
happy Hol t run away from your feelings
oh look at them getting along mm-hmm
your shipments got screwed up in the
computer the wrong Parts went to the wrong
cities now all hell is broken no believe it
so hard 6 p.m tomorrow I'll be unemployed it's
not too late no it's just always lost moment of
a movie they're gonna turn it around we've
actually learned shipping addresses didn't
we yes and they were right when I put them
into my computer I swear how could maybe if
you weren't such a rebel you could avoid
don't worry because I quit so you won't
have to put up with anything anymore oh no I
called about a ticket to Cuyahoga Falls her
name's Brock right that flight's going through
Columbus let me just call that up for you oh
excuse me gotta get them on the Jerry Springer
Show don't you know we can get busted for that
I'm sorry I did not know that right now we
got a bigger problem that is Beer's coming
back up oh Lord oh no oh my God cops damn it
Richard the whole car smells like beer they're
never gonna believe I wasn't drinking when I
stopped the car run out screaming no problem
I go I'm gonna make it seem
like it was something else yeah
oh no Jeremy roll around on the ground
forget that I'm starting to swell up
I'm allergic to bees me too they're huge we go
to Chicago tell them we're not for sale he seems
like a good guy on TV he'll understand yeah he's
dreaming yeah all right you got this Tommy Boy
we're screwed no tickets to Chicago not even
standby there's got to be something we can do
no you got any money because I got a plan
you're gonna fly the plane oh my God I
had a nice surprise they said we were
going to be short-handed this leg you
touch Owen could you handle the announcements
okie dokie oh no although what are the odds of
us actually hitting a leg my money
says if anything it's gonna be a
mountain to inflate put it around your
neck and yank down on the tap oh my God
impressive
this is stressing me out Tommy
ah I'm okay I'm fine I'm fine now oh my God
that looks painful as an
actor whoa look at this place
that's massive he is the king where is he where
is he listen up this will only take a second
oh no he's surrendered what sir what exactly
happened here he came out of the Shadows behind
me and after he hit me many many times with me
I had to give him my gun you know I've got kids
Jesus Jesus galahan's a premium name that's
what I'm buying I can make the parts in one
of my factories put them in a Callahan box
and sell them in my stores at a premium price
wow um so much production I was gonna say
like there's a lot of stuff there's a lot
oh my God what a reveal don't feel bad this chain
of events was set in motion a long long time ago
you and your bald-headed friend here you did what
you poor guy this is Callahan sir Hey sir what
a so-called family deserted me
Michelle's mad at me I lost the
factory the town's going under and I'm
out of a job could have done without that
when we first started out I thought you
just walked through this like you walk
through everything else but you didn't
your dad would have been proud of you
and you got a friend out of it now I know it
doesn't matter because you have so many but uh
I don't oh it's like SpongeBob and Patrick
did you guys know John's really bald what
he wears a toupee yep really no oh the
airport I was going home and I saw your
stepbrother and your stepmother and he
was kissing her so with his tongue so
you lied to my dad they're con artists
they suckered him they lied to my dad
what is the plan here why I'm on
fire he's gonna blow up the building
sorry boys hopefully we'll just be in and out
oh my God he's white and uh no cops wouldn't
want things to get messy that I didn't really see
that coming that he'd pretend to be a terrorist
my your hands move quickly quickly only
when I see something I want Mrs Callahan
oh that's so gross look at
this human bomb on the news
oh yeah I buy brake pads off him I
thought we were watching cartoons
right now those workers are in danger losing
their jobs I'll be happy to look into it I
can get a good look at a T-bone by sticking
my head up a bull's ass but I'd rather take
the butcher's word for it he nailed it this is an
order for half a million Callahan brake pads to be
sold in your stores made by the American
working man for the American working man
um smart man it would be my great pleasure I
mean what have I got to lose a great American
product right beat him at his own game you
lost your shares to your bank you don't even
have a right to be here Steve funny you
should bring that up because I'm not sure
that you have the right to be here oh yes
get it girl how can Beverly be married to
Paul and my dad at the same time what I think
it means is your marriage to my dad was never
legal which also means that Beverly share still
belonged to Tommy yes I believe that's right Mr
Riley I'd say that's right none of you guys
seem surprised at all yeah I was like um
why
want to step over to my club
and we'll grab something to eat
away with this it's great Tommy thanks
way to go Tommy Kelly kiss her do it
uh new president of Callahan Otto Tom
Callahan Jr he went from Tommy Boy to
Tommy Mann ever since I was a kid you
people have been like a family to me
Lewis we built our first Fort together RT I lost
my virginity to your daughter for crying out loud
you know that as long as I'm around I'm gonna bust
my butt and make sure that every last 20
I always has a job right here at Callahan
thumbs up dad got a little problem here I've been
stuck out here for an hour with no wind again I'm
supposed to be at Michelle's for dinner so if you
give me a little help I'd appreciate it if not
don't worry about it that a mermaid it pushes the
boat I still love you and I sure miss you a lot
it's me
paint with all the colors the wind I was
thinking that and then you said it I love
it thanks Dad dad's Pocahontas that's gonna
leave a mark how cute oh that was a sweet film
it was a sweet film all right now let's do
an Easter egg breakdown hidden details all
the things the audience missed Sally take
it away all right um first of all the tone
it really start with the tone
it doesn't start with the tone
um no I think uh it's bizarre to me that
this worked because well Chris Farley is
such an amazing actor and like I know he over
that's his thing as he goes over the top but
um I don't know like you can there's like a quote
that's like it doesn't have to be realistic it has
it just has to be believable and I think he just
nails that to a tea like even though none of it's
really realistic he's just so believable like
his eyes just it's I don't know he's so intense
but it works yeah he's he's very committed uh
yes that's what yeah very committed I mean I
love these kind of whack-a-doodle zany comedies
you know and the especially these 80s ones that
tend to have like a road trip Vibe and you you
pair up people where like one's high energy the
other is low energy and then you watch as they
morph into friends by the end of the film I
like that and they're this vulnerabilities come
out yeah yeah and you know like like I said I I
didn't grow up with Chris Farley you know I feel
like if someone who grows and so I'm not I'm not
I've seen like two sketches of his from snls
one of those classic sketches so I don't I was
like familiar with like kind of the you know the
the the slapstick um physicalities that he would
do but I've never seen him in like a full-blown
performance so to have this sort of introduction
to uh his work here he he has this in endearing
child-like quality that makes a character it
was like there are lines that he makes funny that
normally wouldn't be funny but he finally exactly
maybe cheesier like bad but he somehow still
Nails the delivery on it yeah he's got great
delivery and he's he's he manages to bring a high
level of energy backed with a surprising sincerity
in the way he says things so this movie is one
of those films that surprisingly works because
this could easily have just been very annoying
and frustrating to sit through but I was like
no this is funny and this has a really good heart
and uh while yeah it's like it is cartoonish and
sketch like but it's still a real film at the end
of the day with uh still had a storyline and still
had villains I mean it still had like the classic
formula to like a good movie in this during this
time but yet you're right there were like scenes
that kind of just felt like mini sketches um but
that's I think just like what the audience would
have wanted from them being on SNL oh I think like
the kind of movie it is and the kind of movie was
especially from back then it sort of makes sense
and Lauren Michaels uh producing this film as well
like yeah you know you sort of expect that but it
still it still goes above and beyond to have
a some good messages and character growth he
literally goes from like Tommy Boy to Tommy Man by
the end of the film there was a full character art
guys for both of him and David Spade both of them
yeah because his that that whole scene what he is
learning about the sales I actually thought that
was really clever where you they do have a good
something that's kind of surprisingly poignant
about how you know in life a lot of people
a lot of times in life people feel a little bit
held down by how they performed in school you know
their their formal education but there's so much
more to succeeding in life uh you know based off
of how you feel internally who you are as a person
developing confidence developing Street smarts and
people skills like that usually can outweigh so
much of an academic experience not to Discount an
academic experience but that is something that's
very it doesn't Define you exactly so I thought
that was a surprising yeah surprisingly good
message and and for for the boy who comes from
such a wealthy family who's a very spoiled and
God and everything given to him he he managed
to truly find you know even though people clown
on himself but it was still like a real Underdog
Story where you find yourself sort of rooting
for this buffoon which I was surprised by because
it could have easily like I said it could have
easily just been an annoying movie but it didn't
amount to that and David Spade was newspaper was
good too you know it's like when you step into a
role like that you're you're aware that I can't
compete with Chris Farley so that's right yeah
I'm here to support Chris Farley because if they
were both like super over the top I don't think
it would have worked you know but like the fact
that David Spade played it pretty straight the
whole time is kind of what made it funny yeah um
because you're waiting to see how he'll respond
and like how he'll react to Chris to you know
Tommy was probably his character he still had
some funny moments though that uh I still think
that he there's some good deliveries and stuff
but I thought the word of friendship is great
insults that's the spade for you but the I thought
the I thought the way their friendship um formed
felt natural and it's also nice to get kind of a
I don't know you know normally in in comedies
nowadays Everything feels so like such high stakes
comedy especially with the Buddy movies they
usually have like some kind of action element
involved in them now too and to get a movie plot
that's about you know the Simplicity of saving a
family business and but it's like you're going
into all these these this talk about stuff and
cars yeah automobile industry that is so specific
like it seemed like they really had to know what
they were talking about to a certain degree when
making this film and I was surprised by like this
is I've never really seen a movie that deals so
much with with this whole I think industry I think
that's what grounded it because that might be why
it's such a classic comedy movie because like it
is very different but you're right it's all very
like it feel like I forgot I was watching a movie
when it was they were having the scenes about you
know like the business and everything because I'm
just like oh yeah like I was like genuinely trying
to like listen to everything and you believed
like even all the extras like looked like it legit
looked like uh there's some movies you watch where
extras look like extras you know what I mean yeah
but um like they look fake people like a fake town
or whatever but they generally look like a real
like small town you know like they could work in
a factory and I think that helped too yeah weirdly
really well done I I don't know why I don't know
what's expecting but like the production value on
this was was actually really good I was surprised
by that there were so many sets and animals and
real yeah [__] they think I'm like wow they
really use locations yeah the deer the deer
definitely was like a probably a puppet maybe
even with one like that that quick scene of them
like when they were about to hit it looked like
a slight animatronic um and and then after that
it was like a real deal so I was like whoa like
I didn't at this was obviously before like good
CGI um so they had to get really creative but
it weirdly made it seem more realistic and I I
enjoyed that it was kind of fun even the moths
I was just like so fixated in the scene staring
at it because I'm like I know those aren't real
moths but they looked like they were all flying
in that corner I'm like how are they doing that
um yeah I don't know isn't that weird that we're
so used to CGI that like I just like really hyper
focused on that wow yeah I know that was very I
was I find myself thinking about those things too
uh especially for from the 80s where you feel like
they would want to go a little bit cheaper but
I'm like they threw down for this movie they did
they really need to look real and and I like the
I just like how they they really seem like they
mapped there's a lot of there's a lot of good
visual comedy in here and but you know it's all
like everything goes back to Chris Farley at the
end of the day in this film you know yeah I don't
think anyone else could have played this character
there is such a there is such like a Wonder in his
eyes there and like as as high octane energy as he
is like I really feel like sometimes a personality
like that can be a little off-putting and yeah
yeah he's so Charming you know and I think I don't
know how he does that I really don't because I
feel like any other person that would try to play
that off would kind of come across creepy like how
how are you like how do you look like a toddler
but then also like have a child like Wonder but
then also you you can act like an adult like it's
just kind of it's a fine line but he Nails it and
that's why he's a legend let's uh I'm gonna read a
couple of facts for you oh okay well I just pulled
these up right now because I just thought this
was interesting Rob Lowe played the supporting
role of Tommy's stepbrother but is uncredited the
reason for this is because he wanted it to be a
happy surprise after the script shifted Focus
because the film was originally centered around
the relationship between Tommy and Rob Lowe's
character Paul so for some reason he wanted it to
he has to not be credited that's a weird thing huh
I don't know but apparently was that a weird way
of him being like I don't want to be a part of
this movie no no no I think he wanted it to be
some surprise for some reason I don't know what
the surprise is for though but anyway yeah that's
interesting hey check this out I've I've never
well first I I've just never watched Rob Lowe
and something where I was like creeped out by
him but like for some reason he creeped me out
of this he's done some creepy things in real life
too he's a he's a questionable person sometimes
oh I read his book but whatever oh you read his
whole book yeah I mean it was it never ends so
all right on the list showing the exam grades
of the students at the beginning of the movie
look at the bottom uh this is when he got to when
he gets his D plus right one of the names is Helen
Keller who scored an F and to the right of Helen
Keller is Michael Jackson who also got a d-plus
isn't that interesting well uh
whoa okay I got a long one for you
during filming David's fading Chris Farley
got into a physical altercation on set
there's a whole explanation to here oh there are
times I just really didn't get along really wow
that's surprising apparently there was some [__]
that happened where they they didn't get along
interesting whoa but I don't think I would
have picked up I didn't pick up on that at
all so they're great actors I mean they've
worked together again and they've they've
definitely had an endearing friendship over the
years buried the hatchet but during this film
apparently they didn't get along a lot of the
time maybe sometimes when someone's that big of
a character your initial reaction could be to get
annoyed you know um if you're not used to working
with someone like that so I'm sure he probably
just wasn't used to working with him so closely
for that long what happened this is gnarly okay
here we go I'm going to read this super quick pay
attention Sally pay attention as they landed
in Toronto on an early Sunday morning after
doing SNL in New York Farley was not feeling
well so he went up to his hotel room Spade
not thinking about it had called the Rob Lowe
and they went out to a bar for a drink Farley
found out the next morning and had become very
jealous and throughout the morning would angrily
stare at spade and repeatedly ask him how's Rob
Lowe Spade try to explain and reminded him word
off the wire was that you were sick but Farley
wasn't hearing it later that day they were about
to shoot a scene Spade was sitting on the ground
eating a tuna sandwich and going over his lines
while Farley smoking a cigarette was still
just staring and asking him how's Rob Lowe
Spade was getting annoyed with him at this point
Farley then went over to spade and stomped on his
hand with this sandwich in it oh my God fade
responded by throwing his diet coke on him to
which Farley threw Spade into a wall and pushed
him down a small set of steps before things got
too violent the walkie-talkie called action they
quickly composed themselves and walked in the set
then when it was time for Spade to say his line
he couldn't speak so he stormed offset into the
trailer the director called cut and Farley went
off to his trailer too Spade refused to continue
filming with Farley Farley was so mad that
he needed to hit someone so he tackled the
director's assistant Skippy the parents sometimes
go for hours without talking to each other
they would talk to each other through the director
that is insane Rob Lowe you teared up a friendship
on set sometimes Lisa I didn't know I mean
okay so we had an anger issue that makes sense
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely but is he
still a legend though should I take that back
who Chris Farley as far as of course the legend
okay well I would I don't know you like assaulted
people back then they're two men people wouldn't
cry over something like this and be like men
fighting that's what happened yeah but I've fallen
downstairs before it is not fun there's a small
set of stairs just small yeah you're right but
he was he was completely sober during addiction
though that's crazy uh during filming I mean it
was completely over time and I was like huh yeah
okay but he developed a coffee addiction filming
this movie oh wow there's some amazing things yeah
I could see that yeah that's where I got his
energy I thought it was all natural yeah yeah
wow wow okay there's a lot of facts here
there's so many to go over I'm gonna become
obsessed with learning everything about dogs
what did the movie do well commercially at
least or did it flop uh I mean I know it's uh
I know now it's a cult classic box office hit
uh it did okay I guess it did well and oh yeah
yeah I did well profited okay yeah um but it's
more considered like a cult classic more than
anything yeah but all right yeah that was a fun
film what was it on Paramount plus this whole time
no no I would have had Paramount all right I don't
have Paramount plus so well yeah I mean it's like
the one I don't have okay I use it once a month
tied not even a show I'm just like oh apparently
this thing is I forget I have Paramount plus I get
a lot of subscriptions through my Amazon account
because you can like link up so right I'm always
like I forgot to cancel Showtime like that's my
life oh I've done that before for school that
was annoying but uh here we are all right
Sally well what do you give it out of 10.
um you know an ex boyfriend of mine
we were seeing each other and he was
mad that I hadn't seen this movie and
that's why we broke up so I give it
well it's a healthy relationship no I'm kidding
him I mean he was kind of mad so something about
this healed me you know it closed the chapter
for me so I'd give it a I give it an 8 out of ten
perfect pick up that phone you call that man back
I'll call him and you let him say hey I finally
watched it are you free to watch another movie
oh yes is there a Tommy Boy too I don't think so
all righty guys well check out Sally's if you
just made it this long you're a good person so
check out Sally's Spider-Man Kickstarter
do you sneeze you fart what was that
coughing and I know you've said things a few
times I cough but like I'm still
getting over this awful virus so
I apologize
support Sally has uh she needs this
charity for the hospital visits how
do I see yeah I was supposed to say how
do I sell this so I say I'm homeless
um I'm a homeless person trying to make a fan
film come here and film here guys this is gonna
be my big break because I can't profit off of it
because it's copier in material that is true that
is true you're doing this other kindness for your
heart I really am all right ladies and gentlemen
we'll talk with you soon Sally thank you for
gracing us with your wonderful lovely presence
thank you for having me Greg it was great laughing
with you peace out reject Nation peace out